and now ladies and gentlemen in closing
no we're not we're not finished yet but
I did want to give you something to look
forward to my next awards will be
distributed by one of the screens most
successful leading ladies Barbara rush
and a young man who succeeded in this
business without even trying Robert
Morse
well Barbara we're here let's honor the
people who make documentary films and
who have succeeded rut for best
achievement in a feature-length
documentary film the nominations are the
Anderson platoon Pierre Sean door fur
producer Festival Murray Lerner producer
harvest Carol Ballard producer a King
story Jack live en producer and the time
for burning Williams see Jersey producer
you open fire
the winner is the Anderson platoon prf
in Dover
I will thank you very much the Academy
and I think that Eva Petrov any
qualities it's mostly due to the human
quality of the 33 men of the batoon and
Bebo above all because of the human
quality of its leader other nyet the
latent Jo B Anderson so I'm very proud
to share this honor with them
the nominations for the best
documentaries short subjects are
monument to the dream Charles II
Guggenheim producer a place to stand
Christopher Chaplin producer the
Redwoods Mark Harris and prover
Greenwood producers see you at the
pillar Robert fidget producer and while
I run this race Karl the ragsdale
producer you do this one bombing the
winner is the Redwoods Mark Harris and
Trevor Greenwood
on behalf of King screen productions
Mark Harris the co-producer and dick
chew the photographer we would like to
extend a very sincere thanks to the
Academy for this honor thank you very
much